well up north at Lake Tahoe check this
out more than 400 volunteers spent the
morning after the Fourth of July
cleaning up this 8 500 pounds of trash
that was left on the beaches after July
4th celebrations this is disgusting
cigarette butts plastic food wrappers
cups and cans beach toys even barbecues
that had to be removed from six popular
Beach sites around Beach sites around
Lake Tahoe that's according to the
non-profit keep Tahoe Blue it's a
volunteer program that helps keep Lake
Tahoe clean volunteers have helped clean
up the shores since
2014. oh my goodness that's just that's
sad is what that is can't believe
anybody would walk away from that much
trash